[Música]
e
a
escala en parís
braulio more
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en parís un programa de radio
france internacional en colaboración con
la televisión france24 en español en la
que damos la palabra a los políticos
artistas personas del mundo de las
ciencias de las artes de la cultura y
claramente de la sociedad civil hoy
vamos a viajar a méxico al sureste del
país concretamente al estado de chiapas
donde hace 28 años el levantamiento
zapatista conducido por el ejército
zapatista de liberación nacional ez ln
sorprendió al mundo entero es desde allí
desde el estado de chiapas donde 28 años
después las comunidades indígenas han
lanzado un grito de alerta para
denunciar lo que son las agresiones y
otros actos de hostigamiento de parte de
grupos paramilitares del gobierno de las
autoridades locales estatales y del
propio gobierno federal según argumentan
ellos cuál es la situación de esas
comunidades indígenas hay testimonios
que confirmen dichas agresiones qué es
lo que se puede hacer hoy en día para
hablar de ello saludamos aquí en nuestro
estudio la presencia de antoine vivo
buenos días santos usted hizo parte
recientemente de una de las
internacionales que he estado observando
precisamente lo que está sucediendo en
esas comunidades indígenas de chiapas mi
primera pregunta es cómo se enteraron
ustedes de que había una demanda de las
comunidades indígenas para que
observadores de carácter internacional
viajaran a chiapas en calidad de
testigos y pudieran confirmar lo que
está sucediendo allá
el año pasado con mi pareja decidimos de
que íbamos a viajar unos meses en méxico
y por eso nos interesamos al país y como
en francia tengo mis padres que compran
el café zapatista es así que me interesa
que me interese mucho al movimiento y
pues nos dimos cuenta que lo que hacen
en chapas eso impresionante no
desarrollar su autonomía un sistema
político muy democrático y
anticapitalista y quisiéramos dar un
compromiso político a nuestro viaje y ya
sino así si buscamos en formas
informaciones y nos dimos cuenta que era
posible de integrar brigadas si eres de
observación como observador de los
derechos humanos y así de apoyar al
movimiento de una manera pues muy
interesante para que nuestro público lo
sepa este café zapatista al que hace
referencia de hampón son las comunidades
que producen es una región que se
produce café de muy buena calidad y lo
venden en cooperativa hacia el exterior
hay organismos que lo compran desde el
exterior lo distribuyen generalmente por
varias partes en europa américa latina
etcétera antón dibujo que son esas
brigadas civiles de observación
las brigadas si eres de observación es
un proyecto que está manejado
desarrollado por el frayba que es un
centro de cifra de la de las casas que
es un centro de derechos humanos que
está en chiapas en el san cristóbal de
las casas y básicamente las brigadas se
componen de
observadores de derechos humanos
personas de muchas partes del mundo como
como yo de francia pero en nuestra
brigada había una persona de agentes de
alemania y la idea es que haya ojos y
oídos en comunidades indígenas en la
resistencia para denunciar lo que pasa
lo que pasa allá entonces son
comunidades que piden la presencia de
observadores internos e internacionales
para documentar lo que pasa allá porque
están en una situación de conflicto
si la idea es de documental lo que pasa
las agresiones los
[Música]
si las violaciones de derechos humanos y
denunciar lo que pasa y también
distensión a los que la situación que se
vive en la comunidad porque las brigadas
tiene también un efecto disuasivo
con la presencia de observadores
internacionales lo que pasa es que
muchas veces hay menos hostigamientos
hay menos agresiones porque si ese es un
efecto disuasivo que se puede observar
cuando haya cuando hay observadores en
la comunidad ahora bien cómo se forman
esas brigadas quién la financia
pues
si se forman que para participar hay que
contactar el centro de derechos humanos
después hay que los observadores que
quieren participar se van a comprar su
boleto de avión para ir a chapas o sea
usted se pagó sus pasajes de avión
concretamente sí sí es como el centro de
derechos humanos fray bartolomé de las
casas no financian nada solamente se van
a dar una formación sobre el contexto de
chiapas a explica todas
las misiones
pues el conflicto que hay en la
comunidad y los observadores pues
entonces pagan su
su boleto de avión y después van a
comprar por ejemplo toda la comida que
necesitan por los que van a hacerla en
la comunidad
[Música]
antonio usted junto con juliette
martínez estuvo justamente dos semanas
en la comunidad de san gregorio para
testimoniar lo que está sucediendo ahí
yo me preguntaba dos semanas no es muy
poco para darse cuenta realmente lo que
sucede no existe el riesgo precisamente
de que haya una lectura un poco
falsa de lo que está sucediendo sobre el
terreno pues para nosotros dos semanas
era suficiente para entender un poco lo
que pasa porque cada día hablamos con
los habitantes de la comunidad de nuevo
san gregorio nos explicamos lo que lo
que pasa cada día lo que pasó desde dos
años allá
y para nosotros será suficiente para
darnos cuenta de del sufrimiento que hay
allá de la situación muy difícil que se
vive
si obviamente no hablamos con el otro
lado y
si las personas que los habitantes de la
comunidad de nuevo san gregorio llaman
los invasores
porque si es obvio que no se puede
hablar con ellos porque no se puede
salir de la comunidad entonces
por esa razón se puede pensar que hay
una lectura un poco parcial pero
llegamos allá como observadores de
derechos humanos
enviados por el frayba que es un centro
de derechos humanos que no es parte del
movimiento zapatista y que no es parcial
entonces confiamos totalmente con ese
centro y con su trabajo porque
si analizaron la situación allá y
decidieron que era necesario demandar
observadores y
pues así justamente usted en tanto que
observador junto con william martínez
pudieron testimoniar de algún tipo de
agresión de qué tipo de agresión
eventualmente ustedes fueron testigos
bueno lo que vimos allá era que había al
hombre después en todas partes
básicamente lo que lo que pasó el que
pasa allá es que hay un grupo que se
llaman los invasores que aquí llegó y
que empezó a quitar todas las tierras de
la comunidad y a encerrar los campos la
milpa los campos de maíz
con alambre de púas para sí para robar
las tierras y
entonces lo que vimos es el nombre de
poda también en el hombre
alrededor de la escuela secundaria
lo que pasa es que los alumnos no pueden
ir a la escuela secundaria porque hay al
hombre en todas partes y es peligroso
también vimos que para para hacer sus
labores cotidianas como para buscar
líneas hay que cruzar el hombre todos
los días y a veces los habitantes se
lastiman y también nos salen cuando hay
personas de los invasores en los campos
porque es un peligro de
encontrarlos y entonces eso es lo que me
dieron testimonio concretamente este
tipo de ataques son ataques
generalizados ustedes lo vieron en la
comunidad nuevo san gregorio pero tienen
noticias de otras comunidades que hayan
sido agredidas y concretamente qué hacen
las autoridades locales para evitar este
tipo de agresiones sí creo que hay otras
otras comunidades que están atacadas con
por ejemplo moisés gandhi es una
comunidad zapatista que está en la misma
región de
nuevo san gregorio y ahí hay un grupo
paramilitar que se llama ahorcado que
dispara
así que dispara balas adentro de la
comunidad y entonces es una situación
muy violenta y creo que hay otras
comunidades también en chiapas donde hay
conflictos
así y las autoridades
pues no hacen nada para evitar esos
tipos de conflictos al contrario
voy a tienen un interés con esos
conflictos porque para ellos es la
posibilidad de debilitar el móvil el
movimiento zapatista y también otras
comunidades indígenas en la resistencia
porque pues si tienen que quieren
accesar el territorio para el territorio
así es y entonces hay una cosa que llama
mi atención a las comunidades indígenas
zapatistas precisamente acusan decíamos
al gobierno local a los grupos
paramilitares al gobierno estatal e
incluso al gobierno federal de ser
dijéramos cómplice o de incentivar este
tipo de agresiones y al mismo tiempo el
gobierno del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador dice que las comunidades
indígenas son aliados y que los respeta
mucho usted que pudo constatar en ese
terreno
si
lo que constatamos es que hay una
diferencia entre lo que dice el
presidente de mexico que parece estar
como
pues que quiera borrable y si favorable
a las comunidades indígenas pero en
realidad lo que lo que constatamos
hablando con las personas de las
comunidades es que la situación es peor
desde que
de que habló esta presidente de méxico
porque si es que escuchamos
discursos de hambre antes de venir y era
una pregunta que teníamos cuando
los habitantes de nuevo san gregorio
entonces preguntamos cómo está la
situación desde que hay este nuevo
presidente y nos dijeron que es peor las
fotografías que acompañan de esta
emisión que está viendo nuestro público
son fotografías que ustedes tomaron
durante su estancia como observadores
hay en chapas que quisieron mostrar con
estas fotografías es una manera de
testimonio para ver lo que sucede
precisamente en un conflicto que aparece
relativamente invisibilizado a nivel
internacional
a través de
difundir un poco nuestra experiencia de
hablarle con de hablar de lo que lo que
pasa allá en esa comunidad porque es si
es una
es una manera de poner la luz en una
situación muy difícil y también lo que
tratamos de hacer es de hablar de las
brigadas acciones de observación para
dar ganas a personas como nosotros de sí
de participar y de apoyar al movimiento
que sí que para nosotros es una
inspiración en 30 segundos un mensaje en
particular que usted quisiera hacer
pasar después esta experiencia muy
brevemente sí creo que el movimiento
zapatista es el movimiento muy
democrático y que tenemos que pues que
apoyarlo y que si hay personas que
quieren hacer un compromiso político es
una manera
[Música]
fácil
pues de apoyar a un movimiento con las
vidas civiles de observación muchísimas
gracias estamos llegando ya al final de
este escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle precisamente a antoine
dibujó su presencia en nuestros estudios
gracias a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita aquí la próxima semana en otra
fiscal en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]